voici tout ce qui va changer en france à
partir du 1er septembre les personnes
faisant un don de spermatozoïdes de
rossi tout embryon doivent accepter que
leur identité soit révélée aux enfants
issus de ces dons à leur majorité s'ils
en font la demande les dons antérieurs
au 1er septembre 2022 reste peu hanoi le
dispositif anti gaspillage ou epub à
être testé dans plusieurs villes le
concept seuls les foyers ayant affiché
sur la boîte aux lettres l'étiquette ou
epub recevront des imprimés les bourses
étudiantes et les allocations de rentrée
scolaire augmente de 4% les élèves de
primaire doivent désormais faire 30
minutes de sport chaque jour en plus des
trois heures hebdomadaires de ps la
prime carburant passe de 18 à 30
centimes d'euros par litre à paris de
stationnement des scooters et motos
devient payant avec un tarif moitié
moins cher que celui des voitures le
stationnement reste gratuit pour les
deux roues électriques de nombreuses
aides au logement sont augmentés de 3 5%
la loi de protection des lanceurs
d'alert censé mieux les protéger eux et
leur entourage entre en vigueur de
nombreuses allocations et pensions soit
augmenté de 4% tous les emprunteurs
peuvent désormais changer à tout moment
et sans frais leur assurance de prêt
l'augmentation du plafond journalier des
tickets restaurant de 19 à 25 euros qui
devait se faire ce 1er septembre est
finalement repoussé au plus tard au 1er
octobre